a Charlie Brown Christmas has become a
bona fide holiday staple if you're an
adult who's watched the show multiple
times
there are several details you may have
noticed about this seasonal classic that
younger viewers likely miss let's
investigate
just as Pigpen is perpetually surrounded
by dust clouds and Schroeder is almost
always next to his piano Linus is hardly
ever seen without his trusty blue
blanket he's got it with him outside in
the snow and inside during rehearsals
for the Christmas play - you've got to
get rid of that stupid blanket
he's quite clearly attached to the thing
perhaps a little too attached you think
you're so smart with that blanket what
are you gonna do with it when you grow
up maybe I'll make it into a sport coat
you can't blame Linus for not wanting to
let the blanket go it appears to be made
of 100% pure magic it gets dragged
through the snow all day without getting
soggy and even serves as a remarkably
accurate slingshot wait did he just ice
skate with his security blanket in his
hand and now this is happening later on
Lucy tries to get him to put down the
blanket so that he can dress up like a
shepherd for the Christmas play that's
when Linus reveals that the blanket can
shape-shift forming a perfect headdress
complete with a band in the middle who
manufactures this Swiss Army security
blanket we simply must have one a good
chunk of a Charlie Brown Christmas takes
place at the local auditorium where the
Peanuts gang is getting ready to put on
a Christmas play Charlie Brown is roped
into the production after he tells Lucy
about his holiday depression and she
feels the play will help him get into
the holiday spirit you want me to be the
director of the Christmas play sure
Charlie Brown we need a director you
need involvement Charlie Brown eagerly
leaps into his role as director but he
can't seem to get anyone to listen to
him perhaps more importantly no one
seems entirely clear on what play
they're even putting on at one point
Lucy hands out scripts to various kids
for roles like innkeeper and Shepherd
obviously this suggests the nativity
play but then she also asks
be can you be a sheep how about a cow
how about a penguin quite the menagerie
all told to complicate matters further
Schroeder keeps trying to score the play
with upbeat jazz and at one point lucy
suggests herself for aplomb sounding
role so is this some sort of highly
conceptual staunchly avant-garde
nativity play
is it a variety show does anyone really
know to our ears it all sounds a tad bit
unfocused a Charlie Brown Christmas
begins by focusing on the titular
characters own lack of satisfaction with
the holiday he tells Linus in no
uncertain terms christmas is coming but
I'm not happy I don't feel the way I'm
supposed to feel he also repeatedly
complains that the holiday has grown too
commercial his Scrooge eNOS reaches
dizzying new heights when he sees Snoopy
putting up a bunch of decorations on his
doghouse that's when he realizes the
Beagle is decking the halls for a
Christmas light contest so that's
promising a cash prize oh no my own dog
gone commercial I can't stand by the end
of the special we learned that Snoopy
not only entered the contest but managed
to win first place we admit that
Snoopy's decorated dog house looks very
charming but we have a few concerns
he puts lights up all around the roof
Hanks a theoretically festive chain or
two and even tops it all off with a star
there's nothing wrong with his
decorations per se but it ultimately
amounts to little more than a strand of
lights and a couple of baubles hanging
around a doghouse how did this doghouse
win out over all those suburban
properties come to think of it Charlie
Brown's neighbors don't appear to have
put in much of an effort
where's everyone's Christmas lights
apart from the Ultra commercial
Christmas tree lot it looks like people
just weren't feeling it that year maybe
Charlie Brown had every reason to be
depressed when the Christmas play
rehearsals don't seem to be working
Charlie Brown makes a passionate plea
look Charlie Brown what do you want the
proper mood we need a Christmas tree
Lucy agrees and advises Charlie Brown
get a great big aluminum Christmas tree
Charlie Brown and Linus subsequently
head to the tree lot where they
ultimately decide to take the scrawny
real tree that remains one of the most
famous parts of the show the whole point
of the scene is that Charlie Brown picks
this little twig of a tree which mirrors
his own feelings about the season but
when you look around at the rest of the
lodge you may have some questions it's
arranged like a traditional Christmas
tree lot but it soon becomes clear that
the tiny tree is the only real tree
there the rest are made of aluminum it
really brings close to a person setting
aside the lack of real trees for a
moment let's ask the obvious question
who's selling aluminum Christmas trees
outside where it's clearly been snowing
snow is wet and the trees are made of a
delicate metal surely that would have
messed up the merchandise snow when
Charlie Brown brings the tiny tree back
from the lot and presents it to his
friends they call him names and full-on
laugh at him then Linus makes a stirring
speech passionately quoting scripture in
the hopes of emphasizing the true
meaning of Christmas
that's when Charlie Brown decides to
take the tree home he thinks he can
convince everyone that they were wrong
to make fun of the tree so long as he
can get the decorations right Charlie
Brown gives up after the tree nearly
breaks in half from the weight of just
one ornament but then the other kids
come along to help
Linus wraps his blanket around the base
and the kids use all the decorations
from Snoopy's doghouse to fill out the
rest of the tree by the time the kids
are done decorating with all the lights
and baubles the tree looks like it's
grown about a dozen extra branches and a
whole bunch of extra needles in fact it
looks like a completely different tree
is it a Christmastime miracle what's
going on here check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you